et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Laurent Jacoby bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés de Moselle
porte-parole du rassemblement national
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par Fabrice
wesser Redon du groupe Evra les journaux
de l'Est de la France dont la moitié
bonjour Laurent
jacobelli deux motions sont sur seront
donc débattues et mise au vote cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale dont
une du rassemblement national on va en
parler est-ce que vous pensez réussir à
faire tomber le gouvernement il le faut
c'est une urgence c'est impératif les
Français ne veulent pas de cette réforme
des retraites le l'Assemblée nationale
ne veut pas de cette réforme des
retraites c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de majorité pour voter ce
texte que la première ministre a dégainé
le 49-3 et donc il faut maintenant aller
au bout de la logique il faut dire non
non madame borne qui a porté ce projet
d'une manière j'allais dire radicale
autoritaire fermée presque sectaire et
non au projet lui-même parce qu'on ne
peut pas expliquer aux Français qui vont
devoir travailler deux ans de plus pour
au final gagner moins lorsqu'ils seront
à la retraite que vous pensez que
suffisamment députés ou voter cette
censure il en faut 287 écoutez moi ce
que j'espère c'est que les députés
seront courageux et non sectaires on a
vu ce que ça donnait le sectarisme de la
nupes par exemple lorsqu'il refusait de
voter une motion référendaire tout
simplement parce que c'était la nôtre
aujourd'hui les Français auraient pu
avoir à décider par leur vote pour ou
contre cette réforme il ne le peuvent
pas à cause de la nups il faut voir
aussi si le sectarisme du gouvernement
n'a pas d'état sur les républicains
parce que c'est la l'enjeu il y a
beaucoup de députés républicains qui ne
veulent pas cette réforme qui ne veulent
plus de ce gouvernement iront-ils
jusqu'au bout de la logique nous
l'espérons et c'est pour un peu libérer
les esprits créer un peu de sérénité que
Jordan Bardella a été très clair si un
député les républicains vote pour la
motion de censure et qu'il y a des
solutions et bien il ne trouvera pas
face à lui de candidats du rassemblement
national
comme la règle du jeu a été un peu
faussée comme le président de la
République a d'abord essayé de les
acheter puis les a menacés avec la
dissolution pour faire en sorte de Ré
trouver la règle du jeu qu'il puisse se
décider en leur âme et conscience nous
avons décidé de leur ôter un poids vous
faites un peu pareil non non non
des manœuvres qu'il y a autour d'eux
nous sommes conscients que leur
état-major les a lâchés que Monsieur
ciotique monsieur Marleix sont plus
promptes aller à la soupe que de
défendre l'intérêt général et bien
puisqu'ils sont dans cette situation les
quelques députés qui veulent voter la
motion de censure il faut les aider à
passer à l'acte c'est une façon
d'anticiper une éventuelle dissolution
non mais on doit la préparer toutes les
éventualités doivent être étudiées que
la motion de censure passe ou ne passe
pas qu'il y ait des solutions ou pas
dissolution moi je suis étonné du
détournement des outils institutionnels
par le Président de la République et son
gouvernement d'abord le détournement du
49-3 pour faire passer en force cette
réforme et puis cette menace de la
dissolution détournement du 49 tout
simplement vous vous aurez remarqué que
l'Assemblée nationale n'a jamais voté
pour ou contre ce texte c'est quand même
terrible dans une démocratie
parlementaire
mais parce que le débat n'est pas arrivé
au bout non seulement par
l'irresponsabilité et la violence de la
nupesse mais parce que ça arrangeait
bien le gouvernement qui a trouvé là un
allié et puis là on nous sort le 49-3 le
49-3 normalement c'est quand le Premier
ministre n'a pas de majorité dans son
propre camp là oui mais ils sont pas
majoritaires c'est vrai mais là madame
la Première ministre a dégainé 49-3
parce qu'elle a fait des comptes et
qu'elle a vu que le projet ne passerait
pas c'est donc finalement un moyen de
contourner l'Assemblée nationale faut
que ça cesse
issu du compromis entre député et
sénateurs
excusez-moi il y avait une majorité de
de LR dans la boucle de elle est
officielle et j'allais dire qui sont
aujourd'hui finalement fusionnés
absorbés par la macronie si c'est ça
l'opposition alors moi je suis dans ce
étoile
pourquoi vous avez déposé une notion de
censure qui n'a a priori aucune chance
de passer alors qu'il y a une motion de
censure transpartisanes d'abord on était
pas sûr que la motion de censure de du
groupe liotte de l'Assemblée nationale
qui est cette notion sociale que vous
appelez transpartisan puisse avoir le
nombre de députés requis pour être
présentés donc il fallait une motion de
censure et puis nous avons compris que
les Français avaient vu en marine Le Pen
et en les députés du groupe
rassemblement national les premiers
opposants à la réforme de la retraite
c'est ce que disent tous les sondages
d'opinion pourquoi est-ce que nous
sommes les premiers opposants parce que
nous faisons une opposition ferme
déterminée mais raisonnable nous jouons
le jeu des institutions contrairement
aux excités de laupes et donc comme nous
étions vus par les Français comme un
recours à cette réforme il était logique
que nous présentions nous-mêmes une
motion de censure est-ce que vous
appelez les députés les républicains à
voter votre notion de censure et pas
celle de l'iode et de la nuque toutes
les motion de censure s'ils le peuvent
mais qu'ils en vote au moins une et j'ai
je vais être honnête avec vous mais oui
mais peu importe laquelle l'objectif
c'est de d'en finir avec cette réforme
c'est demander à Madame borne de rentrer
chez elle et d'envoyer un signal très
fort au président de la République ce
président de la République qui n'écoute
que lui-même qui ne voit que lui-même
qui ne pense qu'à lui-même il est temps
qu'il pense au 67 autres millions de
Français sur certains députés les
républicains n'exclut pas de voter la
voix de vous avez des discussions ces
derniers jours avec les députés à l'air
alors pas de tractations si c'est le
sens de votre question mais vous savez
on parle à l'Assemblée nationale de
collègues à collègues on a parfois des
divergences et parfois des des
communautés de pensées et sur cette
question là il y a beaucoup de députés
les républicains qui soient sont contre
la réforme parce qu'ils sont gaullistes
sociaux et que elle est contraire au
modèle social voulu par le général de
Gaulle soit parce qu'ils sont choqués
par la forme et qu'ils tiennent beaucoup
à la démocratie parlementaire et qu'ils
ont l'impression qu'on leur a volé leur
rôle qu'on a vidé le rôle de députés et
ils veulent protester contre cela donc
oui je crois sincèrement qu'il reste
quelques députés LR sincère et vous les
appelez à vous rejoindre ces députés à
l'air qui voteraient la motion vous
savez nous on est très clair tous ceux
qui se sentent patriote tous ceux qui
veulent sortir le pays de leur dire dans
laquelle il a été plongé par l'extrême
centre de Monsieur Macron tous ceux qui
veulent travailler à ce que la France
soit à nouveau debout sont les bienvenus
avec nous et notamment notamment bien
sûr vous appelez ceux qui mettent la
motion bien sûr s'ils se sentent
partagés des valeurs communes ne nous
divisons pas la France mérite mieux que
ça c'est la notion de censure est
rejetée cet aprèm dit si l'émotion de
censure sont rejetées est-ce que vous
admettrez que le Parlement à parler que
cette réforme est adoptée et que la
contestation de la CS pas que le
Parlement a parlé je mettrai que le
gouvernement a imposé sa réforme par des
moyens institutionnels il n'a pas violé
la constitution même s'il en a détourné
l'esprit
du vote d'émotion de censure un vote
aussi pour ou contre la réforme des
retraites Adil dit c'est le vote de
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette réforme
des retraites et que tous les députés
qui sont contre la réforme vote la
motion de censure mais vous savez c'est
pas la dernière bretelle de sortie avant
l'autoroute on n'est pas distinguer dans
cette réforme il y aura un recours
peut-être au Conseil constitutionnel il
y aura d'autres élections il y aura
peut-être la volonté d'Emmanuel Macron
de retirer lui-même son projet nous ne
céderons à rien nous utiliserons tous
les moyens à notre possession pour faire
en sorte que les Français ne se voient
pas matraquer par cette réforme injuste
et inhumaine donc pour en revenir à la
question initiale vous admettrez que la
contestation se poursuit ah mais bien
sûr tant que les gens veulent s'exprimer
qu'ils le fassent dans le cadre de la
loi et sans aucune violence et j'insiste
bien là-dessus tant que Monsieur
Darmanin joue son rôle à la fois
d'autoriser les manifestations légales
et pacifiques et en même temps d'arrêter
les Black Blocs et bien oui évidemment
cette réforme ne peut pas passer elle ne
doit pas passer les Français n'en
veulent pas 9 actifs sur 10 n'en veulent
pas le l'Assemblée nationale n'en veut
pas il y a un moment il faut écouter la
démocratie ce pays ne peut pas être
gouverné contre le peuple et pourtant
hier soir Emmanuel Macron a dit souhaité
que la réforme puisse aller au bout de
son cheminement démocratique dans le
respect tous que dites-vous on a tous eu
je crois lors des repas de famille ce
petit gamin de 5 ans qui avait cassé son
jouet et qui voulait absolument qu'ici a
gripper qui hurlait qui n'entendait pas
raison c'est un peu la définition
d'Emmanuel Macron oui il a pondu il a
pondu une réforme immature illogie
malfagoté et injuste et alors que tout
le monde lui dit que cette réforme n'est
pas bonne même ceux d'ailleurs qui
voudrait un durcissement des règles il
s'y agrippe c'est son totem c'est son
doudou il veut aller jusqu'au bout
bouffi d'orgueil probablement et absent
dans son esprit avec l'absence dans son
esprit du sens de l'intérêt général ce
président de la République c'est emmuré
lui-même dans la forteresse qu'il a
construit il est isolé seul avec un
gouvernement à la botte avec d'ailleurs
des personnalités assez faibles qui
supportent les diktates quotidiens du
président et puis avec un reniement du
Parlement tout ça ne peut pas durer bien
longtemps
un vote sur le texte un vote sur le
texte issu des conclusions de la
commission de l'expéritaire oui au Sénat
avec des sénateurs LR qui sont plus
macronistes que Macron lui-même qui ont
fait du fait d'aller à la soupe une
espèce de doctrine je crois qu'ils sont
très décalés de leur électorat et que si
aujourd'hui la candidate à la
présidentielle DLR a fait 4%, c'est
parce qu'ils ont trahi à peu près tout
leur tout leur toute leur doctrine et
tout ce en quoi ils croyaient et doit
s'adresser aux Français Emmanuel Macron
écoutez en tout cas il les évite pour
l'instant ça c'est sûr c'est à dire
qu'il y a une réforme qui est quand même
majeure ce système social qui tenait qui
était un ciment en France et une
fraternité en France depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale il a voulu le
casser sans parler aux Français
l'impression qu'il est plus prote à
faire des voyages internationaux à se
retrancher derrière des discours parfois
insipides que de parler du fond on verra
bien s'il a le courage
qu'il regarde les Français dans les yeux
et qu'il leur explique pourquoi il veut
cette réforme cette réforme qui
aujourd'hui n'a plus aucun sens même
budgétaire qui n'a aucun sens social qui
n'a aucun sens
budgétaire
ne sera même pas d'économie et puis vous
savez depuis le début pas non non parce
que cette réforme ne devrait même pas
avoir lieu mais depuis le début c'est à
mon sens vous savez qu'en 1 en français
sur deux arrivent à la retraite soit
malade soit chômeur les économies faites
dans les caisses de retraite demain
seront des surcous dans lesquelles
chômage je veux dire un enfant de 5 ans
là pour le coup pour le comprendre donc
il est entêté une écoute personne il
serait temps qu'il parle aux Français ou
peut-être vous trouvez qu'il a pas fait
justement de concessions il est passé de
65 à 64 depuis le début ça c'est ces
fausses concessions vous savez c'est des
négociations de marchands de tapis on
sait qu'on veut vendre le tapisson on
commence à 500 pour faire croire aux
clients qu'on lui a donné quelque chose
là il est parti de 65 ans pour faire
plaisir aux LR il a abandonné à 64 mais
ça reste deux ans de trop deux ans
inutiles deux ans ou beaucoup de gens ne
seront pas la retraite mais seront
chômeurs tout cela n'a aucun sens
de mesures sociales c'est 40% de ce que
rapporte la réforme vous vous a amené la
France à 3000 milliards de dettes
l'homme qui a laissé faire un déficit
commercial de 170 milliards
non mais ils ont bien augmenté
puisqu'ils ont pris la France elle était
à 2 milliards de vous voyez non que 2000
milliards pardon merci de me corriger
non Monsieur Bruno Le Maire mais n'est
plus un interlocuteur crédit bleu je
veux dire on le voit bien il vient
presque autant que Monsieur Veyron
maintenant c'est vous dire si la motion
de censure est votée qu'est-ce qui se
passe parce que le but d'une notion de
censure c'est quand même de créer une
majorité alternative vous n'arrêtez pas
de souci j'ai alors pas du tout vous
n'arrêtez pas de fustiger la nups vous
avez gouverner avec eux mais si je peux
me permettre ça c'est le storytelling
pour employer un terme anglais du
gouvernement si émotion de censure il
faut une majorité de replis pas du tout
l'Assemblée nationale a priori reste la
même il faut un nouveau gouvernement
mais ça veut pas dire à nous verser un
gouvernement pris par l'opposition
propose une alternative pas le rôle
d'une motion de censure la motion de
censure elle dit deux choses le projet
de loi on en veut pas Élisabeth borne
c'est fini c'est tout mais il ce n'est
pas une alliance entre les parties de
l'opposition faire un projet
gouvernement mais nous qu'est-ce que
vous souhaitez comme majorité derrière
derrière c'est la notion de son surface
et ça c'est je suis pas président de la
République donc ce sera à lui de choisir
peut-être choisir des ministres plus
compétents moins doctrinaires moins
sectaire et un peu plus ouvert au
dialogue est-ce que vous mais
dissolution ça c'est pas automatique
est-ce que vous souhaitez une solution
si la notion de la crainte pas une
seconde
tout ce qui peut faire en sorte que le
rassemblement national soit majoritaire
dans le pays me fera plaisir mais une
fois encore une solution le
rassemblement c'est pas à nous de
décider ça simplement que Monsieur
président de la République sache que
pour nous c'est pas une menace que pour
nous c'est pas une crainte nous sommes
prêts nos candidats sont prêts leur
suppléances sont prêts les mandataires
financiers directeurs de campagne sont
prêts donc si demain il y a des
solutions on sera sur le terrain et
croyez-moi on arrivera beaucoup plus
nombreux à l'Assemblée nation avec le
danger d'une faible participation oui
oui il y a ce danger vous avez raison de
le dire d'abord parce que ça changeait
le cadencement des élections et puis
parce que beaucoup de partis politiques
ont montré un visage qui peut faire peur
aux électeurs les électeurs de gauche
demain voudront-ils aller voter pour des
clowns qui mettent le bazar à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui sont
incapables de proposer des amendements à
peu près rédigés je pense à la nupesse
est-ce que cet après-midi
contre le gouvernement je vais vous dire
un bulletin de vote avec eux mais non
oui d'accord mais alors et alors je veux
dire quand on va voter pour ou contre la
motion de censure cet après-midi il y
aura pas marqué sur le bulletin
attention il vote avec la nupes il y a
pas une once de nupes en moi
et alors le but c'est pas d'être
sectaire c'est pas de défendre son petit
pré carré de ne croire que que les
adhérents du rassemblement national ont
raison surtout l'idée est de dire non à
Madame borne non au gouvernement il y a
un moyen il y a un outil qui est la
motion de censure et bien nous la
voterons vous savez il m'est déjà arrivé
de voter des amendements proposés par la
nupes ce qui est grave c'est que eux
refusent de voter quoi que ce soit à
partir du moment où il y a le nom
rassemblement national ça c'est du
sectarisme ça c'est j'allais dire une
espèce de frein à la démocratie et c'est
pour ça que ces gens qui s'estiment de
gauche qui se déclarent de gauche n'ont
pas voté la motion référendaire on fait
en sorte qu'on n'a pas pu débattre de la
réforme des retraites ils sont
finalement les complices d'Emmanuel
Macron par leur sectarisme est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'elle Marine Le Pen
soit première ministre alors écoutez moi
je me bats depuis que je suis au
rassemblement national pour que Marine
Le Pen soit présidente de la République
je pense que c'est son rôle je pense que
c'est ce que les Français attendent
c'est ils l'ont identifié comme premier
opposante elle est une des personnalités
politiques préférées des Français je
crois qu'elle sort de cette crise de la
réforme des retraites renforcée
puisqu'elle est la seule dans l'image
s'est améliorée et dont les Français se
disent bah elle elle peut nous défendre
alors je pense que si je peux me
permettre et c'est à elle de décider
mais qu'elle se concentre au rôle de
présidente de la République si jamais
nous gagnons les législatives si jamais
il y a des solutions vous savez il y a
plein de talents chez nous et il y aura
d'autres premiers une liste possible
derrière
c'est gentil mais derrière cette réponse
on croit comprendre que vous ne voulez
gouverner avec personne d'autre que le
rassemblement national alors vous m'avez
mal compris où je me suis mal exprimé si
nous nous appelons rassemblement c'est
que nous voulons rassembler tous ceux
qui partagent cet amour de la France
tous ceux qui croient que produire en
France c'est mieux que d'importer de
Chine tous ceux qui croient que la
priorité nationale c'est-à-dire aider
nos compatriotes français c'est mieux
que la préférence étrangère qui
accueille héberge donne des allocations
en priorité aux étrangers tous ceux qui
qui croient que la sécurité la première
des libertés tous ceux qui croient que
la libre entreprise ne va pas ne se
conjugue pas avec le matraquage fiscal
tout cela et bien nous avons vocation à
gouverner ensemble donc non non ce
serait un gouvernement plus large que
nous envisageons un mot puisque Aurélien
Pradier annonce qu'il coûtera la motion
de censure transpartisane cet après-midi
à l'Assemblée nationale quelle est votre
réaction je suis très heureux chaque
voix est une bonne nouvelle et j'espère
qu'il en aura plein d'autres certains se
sont prononcés d'autres ne se prononcent
pas nous ce que nous voulons c'est que
cette motion de censure passe et que
tous les courageux tous les gens de
conviction puissent se retrouver au
dehors des clivages politiques parce
qu'une fois encore on n'est pas là pour
dire on va faire un gouvernement nupes
et l'airfrondeur rassemblement national
c'est pas du tout l'idée on est juste là
pour dire Madame borne faites vos
valises et dans vos valises mettez cette
réforme des retraites les parlementaires
de gauche ont lancé une la procédure
pour un RIP est-ce que vous soutenez
cette procédure est-ce que vous appelez
les Français à signer si l'hypocrisie
avait un nom politique elle
s'appellerait nupes je crois que c'est
nupèces qui ont refusé de voter la
motion référendaire que Marine Le Pen a
proposé juste parce qu'elle venait notre
camp sont des tartuffes c'est à dire
alors que l'Assemblée nationale pouvait
avoir une majorité pour dire oui les
Français doivent voter par référendum
pour ou contre la réforme des retraites
ils se sont défilés ils sont allés à la
buvette et bien aujourd'hui ils nous
disent il va falloir que 4,8 millions de
Français signent un papier pour faire un
référendum moi j'espère que ça arrivera
au bout mais honnêtement c'est quand
même pas la voie la plus simple une fois
encore leur sectarisme les stérilis
complètement et les discrédités les
décrédibilisent pardon vous pensez que
le Conseil constitutionnel va censurer
ce texte je sais pas il y a des choses
étranges dans ce texte le CDI
senior par exemple qu'est-ce qui vient
faire dans une loi de finance
rectificative sociale tout cela est
étrange ça a été rafistolé et puis
est-ce que une réforme des retraites qui
va engager notre France pour des
dizaines d'années peut-être qui change
profondément notre modèle social et
simplement un appendice à la loi sur la
sécurité sociale votée en urgence avant
l'été je suis pas sûr donc on verra bien
mais c'est en tout cas probablement une
piste qu'il faut tenter aussi nous
évoquons la rue tout à l'heure ce
week-end de la permanence parlementaire
d'erikiotype président des républicains
que vous appelez à Bourgoin a été Vand
dans sa circonscription vous cautionnez
bien sûr que non c'est un scandale il
faut que chaque parlementaire et
j'allais dire chaque personne engagée en
politique puisse le faire librement sans
violence sans attaque ce sont des faits
condamnables ils doivent être condamnés
il faut il faut retrouver les
responsables et les arrêter je crois
qu'on peut le débat doit être un débat
d'idées il doit se faire à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat il doit se faire
sur les plateaux de télévision dans les
débats dans les réunions publiques mais
sûrement pas à coup de caillassage
contre des députés c'est une évidence
contre des élus la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale
d'y trouver la démocratie malade en tout
cas des moisies ne va pas bien dit-elle
vous partagez cette analyse oui c'est
étonnant que ceux qui l'ont rendu malade
s'en étonne mais oui c'est vrai elle va
pas bien quand je vois à l'Assemblée
nationale des députés devenus des
députés racailles menacés invectiver
comme ceux de la nupestre qui appelle en
permanence à l'insurrection
vous savez quand on est député ou
militants du rassemblement national
malheureusement reçoit souvent sur les
réseaux sociaux des messages peut
chaleureux mais vous savez qui ne font
que l'écho d'ailleurs à certains hommes
politiques et certains même journalistes
et je ne vous vise pas du tout qui nous
identifient à l'extrême droite qui
disent que nous sommes porteurs de tous
les mots de la société alors forcément
chez des esprits un peu fragiles ça crée
des idées de même que la violence de la
nupesse chez les plus radicaux crée une
espèce de légitimité il se sentent
adoubé par ces députés violents et
hurleurs mais une fois encore la
violence elle est très partagée il y a
aussi la violence du gouvernement qui
fait passer de force un certain nombre
de lois qui méprisent qui ignorent qui
détournent la tête de la misère de
certains Français ce gouvernement qui
est autosatisfait de voir les Français
lutter contre une inflation galopante
des Français qui doivent subir un plein
d'essence avec le litre à 2 euros qui
ont du mal parfois à se loger à se
chauffer à se nourrir et qui dit nous on
fait tout bien on est parfait on est les
meilleurs élèves de l'Europe de quoi
vous plaignez vous cette violence elle
est permanente elle attaque notre régime
parlementaire c'est clair oui elle le
rend plus faible il faut le renforcer
par les convictions par la foi des
convictions l'honnêteté et le respect de
la parole donnée il y a des
manifestations qu'on a vu tous les
cannes un peu tout le week-end dans
plusieurs villes de France est-ce que
vous encouragez ces manifestations
spontanées oui pourquoi pas du moment
qu'elle se fasse une fois encore dans la
paix civile dans le respect des règles
mais comprenez un Français qui veut
s'exprimer aujourd'hui quand il voit que
son vote est bafoué quand il voit
parfois que il a voté pour un député
d'opposition qui se retrouve à soutenir
la majorité quand il voit qu'il a voté
pour un député dit de gauche qui passe
son temps à faire le cirque à
l'Assemblée nationale quand il voit que
sa parole n'est plus entendue et bien il
cherche un autre moyen d'expression vous
savez la démocratie c'est comme une
rivière vous mettez un barrage et le
contourne elle passe par là où elle peut
en revanche il y a des limites à cela
la première c'est le respect de la loi
le deuxième c'est la violence il faut
absolument éviter et condamner toute
violence si ça se fait pacifiquement
pourquoi pas est-ce que vous demandez
aux enseignants de ne pas perturber le
début des épreuves du bac ça fait partie
des limites je pense que il y a beaucoup
de Français qui vont subir de plein
fouet tous les mots qu'on a déjà décrit
qui vont subir cette réforme des
retraites il faut pas leur infliger la
double peine il faut laisser le bac se
faire tranquillement c'est pauvres
jeunes à qui on annoncent déjà qu'ils
n'auront pas de retraite si en plus ils
peuvent pas passer leur bac il faut
penser à leur avenir pour les hôpitaux
pour un certain nombre de transports
d'urgence il faut maintenir un minimum
de services publics naturellement
spontanément je pense que tous ceux qui
font grève sonoraient à avoir ça en tête
oui après la réforme des retraites
Emmanuel Macron semble déterminer à
s'attaquer à la question de
l'immigration qui vous intéresse
pleinement est-ce que vous y voyez un
signe à destination de votre électorat
ah non je crois pas vu les premiers
indices que nous avons sur cette réforme
une nouvelle filière de migration
ouverte
qui amènent au chaos au cas où
sécuritaire au cas où culturel au cas où
social merci mais du coup vous lui
demandez de le retirer cette réforme
d'Emmanuel Macron de le retirer je vais
vous dire je lui demande de lire le
programme de Marine Le Pen et le projet
d'immigration que nous avions que nous
voulons porter en référendum aux
Français il y a tout dedans ressemble du
droit du sol refonte du regroupement
familial fin des allocations pour les
étrangers il y a beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes qui ne s'en inspirent
merci Laurent merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité merci Fabrice à la semaine
prochaine on passe au club de terr